you apparently have proof that you and I
are related is that you and I are
cousins I want to show us how this works
you actually this is real this is
absolutely real yes and this is all of
the weight you starting starting with
you right it starts with me and then we
go through all of this different chain
of events and then we get to me there
you are you are officially my first
cousin once removed husband's third
great-grandfather's fourth great nieces
husband that's absolutely what I love
you like a first pup to be honest I
don't wish to see you again who else am
I related to I know you've loaded it up
I don't know yes we've got let's see
Abraham Lincoln no way all-time hero my
wife side you're married into the
Lincoln's so you married well okay your
wife's first cousin eight times removes
wife's niece's husband so but I do want
to make sure you know not so for you to
not get too big a head you're also
related to all these loser presidents
like Millard Fillmore and Chester Arthur
you're actually very close to Chester
Arthur he like six cousins that makes
sense that's okay who else Kim
Kardashian you are keeping up with them
she is your tenth cousin thrice removed
so three times removed and I will say
again you married into the Kardashians
yeah okay that's okay that's all right
with me
yes yeah yes your wife is a blood
relative and then though this is a told
the last one's kind of a surprise but
let's see it I'm related to this is the
last one Megan Fox oh that's fine very
happy with the other wife thousand three
times from his fourth cousin five times
the fact that we're related kept us from
ever hooking up
until the last ones kind of fun let's
see what a hell is that how are Annie
and I related because he is your 11th
cousin once-removed husband so good God
and and tell me what is it you're hoping
to accomplish with all of this well my
hope is and that's a little idealistic
but I hope that once we realize we're
all part of this big family and we share
99.9% of our DNA that will actually be a
little kinder to each other or at least
a little less douchey its effect in my
life because I you know you know judge
judy of course i related i always found
her incredibly abrasive and just
obnoxious nails on the chalkboard turns
out she's my eighth cousin four times
removed and when i found that out
it changed my perspective i'm like oh
she's not so bad yeah so i'm hoping that
will that a very nice thing you're doing
I find it fascinating the global family
reunion will take place on June 6 you're
gonna get everybody together yeah 2015
for more information you should check
this out go to global family reunion
dot-com aj I'm a real fan thank you for
dangling for AJ Jacobson right back
you